yo what's up everybody precision-made
Luigi here with a video about the
question why is csgo so popular
counterstrike global Offensive is a
multiplayer first-person shooter
released by valve corporation and hidden
path entertainment in 2012 it is the
most recent installment in the
counter-strike series in a wildly
popular game boasting over 500,000
players a day and being a top seller in
steam basically every month since its
release down to mention it usually
dominates one of the top three spots in
twitch every single day in the year
account but why is this game so popular
most games such as call of duty
battlefield or fifa experienced a
decline in the number of players after
peaking around release date however this
game continues to grow and grow what
makes this game gain a larger and larger
fanbase over time rising from an average
15,000 players a day in its first month
to averaging five hundred thousand
players a day today three years after
its release I've come to the conclusion
that cos goes popularity has three main
reasons as follows in order of personal
importance number one it's an easy to
get into fast paced tactical shooter
csgo offers an amazing balance of
tactics and speed of play all while
being fairly easy to pick up and play if
one has any experience with other
shooters another popular game like Call
of Duty is also extremely quick and easy
to get into but it severely lacks and
tactics it's a very simple and Arkady
game if you want to play very tactically
you're going to be kind of put down
battlefield brings in some tactics sub
so it's better than call duty in that
sense but it suffers that it becomes a
little bit slower as a result so it
doesn't keep on as fast play fast-paced
gameplay on the far end of the spectrum
is ARMA a hugely tactical game it blows
everyone else out of the water by five
miles in terms of tactics it has crazy
tactics however ARMA takes a lot more
effort to learn and play just the basics
as opposed to Cod or counter strike or
battlefield because it's going to take a
lot longer to get into not as many
people are going to play so your skill
relies heavily on competitive tactics
while featuring fairly small maps and
very fast gameplay however the tactical
side isn't too taxing in lower end play
which allows the game to be played
pretty easily by a novice cisco has
really mastered the balance between how
fast-paced it is how easy it is to get
into and
tactics inside of it which makes it a
very popular game that a lot of people
want to play as we can see because it's
so popular second reason is pedigree
csgo is the most recent installment in a
14 year old franchise of counter shape
one of its two developers is valve
corporation the owner of the popular pc
program steam because steam has such a
huge sphere of influence in pc gaming
being the largest digital distribution
platform in pc gaming by a long shot
csgo does have a bit an advantage over
competitors on the PC because it is
mainly a pc game the creators of the
game own the largest pc gaming
distributed network so CS goes promotion
is really easy Val can support advertise
and sell csgo all in the easiest and
most optimal way they see fit there's no
middle man because val was already it
generally valve is the middleman so a
developer will have to go through valve
to make all the decisions in terms of
selling it and promoting it on Steam and
because valve already owns team they can
promote it and sell it the exact way
they want to and it's a lot easier
process and now my last reason for it
number three is the market which
actually I'd say this is about even with
pedigree with arms rate update csgo an
independent economy burst out of this
FPS which is not something many
competitors can't offer someone can buy
sell trade offer and bed on skins keys
and cases all revolving around csgo that
make cosmetic changes to all the guns
knives and sidearms in csgo items
ranging from a few cents to hundreds of
dollars can be bought and sold by CS co
enthusiasts constantly this unique
market system adds a whole new side to
the game that can't ice players to say
that normally wouldn't be too interested
in the game so a lot of people can be
interested in csgo solely for the market
or mainly for the market and because
other games don't have this this is a
draw that all will attract a lot of
people so those are my views on why csgo
has become so popular I hope you enjoyed
this video I plan to do more csgo
content on my channel so if you like
this then be sure to stick around for
more stuff alright see you guys later
peace
you